Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 99. Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und heute bin ich mal wieder unterwegs gewesen und befinde mich in der Schweiz, genauer in Bern beim Center für Space Habity,
und.
Genau, also hier geht's,
um das Weltall und wie man da drin wohnen kann, mal kurz gesagt. Genau und möchte heute über eine spezielle Mission sprechen mit dem schönen Namen und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Christopher Brück. Hallo.
Ja, hallo, freut mich.
Dieses Institut hier kümmert sich um was genau eigentlich im Wesentlichen?
Ja, wir sind relativ neu und geht's einfach um Forschung, Excel und Planeten und Planetenforschung mit Fokus auf Bewohnbarkeit,
aber eigentlich sind wir angegliedert hier an das Institut für exakte Wissenschaften und das physikalische Institut wo schon seit der Apollozeit und schon davor im Weltraummissionen begleitet und,
ja Instrumente gebaut wurden für für alle möglichen Missionen. Also eine lange Geschichte und jetzt ein neues Institut mit vielleicht mehr Fokus auf,
Neueste Erkenntnisse über Exoplaneten, die es ja noch nicht so lange gibt.
Genau und darum soll's heute auch gehen. Konkret die Mission CEOPS eben, die sich auf Exoplaneten konzentriert
ich hatte auch schon mal einen Podcast hier in einem Nachbargebäude aufgenommen mit Kathrin Altweg über kosmische Chemie.
Das war das Thema,
Insofern freue ich mich hier noch ein zweites Mal vorbeikommen zu können. Ja, zu Beginn würde ich natürlich gerne mal wissen, wie sind sie eigentlich so zum Weltraum,
gekommen, was was war denn da die Triebfeder?
Ja, ist eine gute Frage, also.
Kindheitstraum oder nichts Besseres eingefallen.
Nein, vielleicht schon Kindheitstraum, also Weltall allgemein und,
Physik eigentlich auch erstmal zunächst und dann wissen wollen, wie alles funktioniert, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält sozusagen. Im weitesten Sinne und dann war ich damals in München und am Studieren, Physik und,
bin dann ans Max-Planck-Institut für extra terrestrische Physik gekommen und habe dort dann eben die Diplomarbeit gemacht und bin dann so in die Astronomierichtung gekommen.
Mehr das einfach das persönliche Interesse und bisschen das Glück was eben gibt an an Projekten.
Die man machen kann und das war noch nicht Weltraum, das war einfach beobachten der Astronomie und dann später Simulationen zur Planetenentstehung.
Und dann bin ich in die Schweiz gekommen, weil ich ja auch eine sehr würde sagen weltweit eine der zwei, drei größten Gruppen weltweit sind, die sich eben mit der Erforschung der Entstehung von Planetensystemen beschäftigen,
und die aber eben auch sehr viele Weltraummissionen machen und bin dann dann von da in die mit Kirbs eben in die in die Weltrauminstrumentation quasi abgedriftet.
Mhm. Okay.
Keops ist jetzt eine von mehreren Missionen, die ja gerade so in irgendeiner Form den Exoplaneten hinterherjagt. Das ist eine relativ kleine Mission.
Was wie ist denn das wie ist denn dieses Projekt geboren worden und vielleicht welchen Mist ist das gewachsen und aus aus welcher Überlegung heraus?
Ja also ganz genau, wie's entstanden ist, kann keiner mehr genau nachvollziehen, aber ich glaube, es war irgendwann mal ein Gespräch zwischen Professor Willi Benz und Didiakelo.
Nicht 2tausend8 weiß nicht mehr genau wo sie überlegt haben was fehlt eigentlich noch im,
Instrumentation und was gibt's irgendwelche Nischen, die man vielleicht mit einer kleinen Mission ausfüllen könnte,
Damals war es ja so, dass Exo Planeten entdeckt wurden, hauptsächlich vom Boden mit Radialmessungen, also mit Spektrummetriemessungen und da bekommt man die Masse der Planeten, aber eben nur die Masse.
Und Transit ist eben eine Methode, die man eben hauptsächlich vom Weltall machen kann und die damals schon erfolgreich, zum Beispiel die Coro-Mission gemacht hat oder später die Kepler-Mission.,
dir aber nur den Radius gibt und die Idee ist immer braucht beides, damit man eben eine dichte Messung machen kann, was dann eigentlich überhaupt erst erlaubt, eine vernünftige Aussage,
Planeten machen zu können und ja und Keops sollte eben diese Lücke füllen, Mate Kepler, das sehr viele Planeten entdeckt,
aber eben meistens sehr weit entfernt ist, sehr dunkle Sterne, von denen man keine Spektren aufnehmen kann und keine Masse bestimmen kann und es gab ihm sehr wenig Überlappung zwischen,
zwei grundsätzlichen Entdeckungsmethoden, so nenne ich's jetzt mal, und Keops sollte eben,
was es jetzt auch macht, sein oder damals hieß es noch nicht Keops, aber eine Mission eben, die Follower machen kann im Weltall von anderen von von Exoplaneten, die man am Boden gefunden hat mit drei Jahre Geschwindigkeitsmethode zum Beispiel. Das war so die Grundidee.
Mhm.
Das heißt so, das was Kepler und ich glaube auch das Test die Testmission derzeit vor allem machen, dass sie einfach erst mal gucken, wo ist denn überhaupt was, sich bestimmte Sterne anschauen und dann erstmal schauen
ist da fällt da irgendwas auf, ne? Die Transit-Methode, wenn halt die Exo-Planeten um die Sonne herum kreisen und Verdunklungen machen oder halt dieses
zittern, weil man halt sehen kann, ah der Stern, der ruckelt so hin und her, da muss wohl irgendwas drum herum fliegen.
Waren dann sozusagen erstmal die Indikatoren, wo man gesagt hat, okay, da ist was, da schauen wir nochmal genauer hin, beobachten das über einen längeren Zeitraum und dann wissen wir so, aha, okay, nach unseren Berechnungen müssten da jetzt drei, vier, fünf, acht, wie viel auch immer, Planeten um diese Sonne herum kreisen, diesen Stern.
Hat man die erstmal auf einer Liste, muss das irgendwann auch mal bestätigen durch Langzeitbeobachtung, aber man weiß halt nicht genug. Man muss eigentlich schärfer hinschauen,
kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Ja und nein, also einerseits ja in Bezug auf vor allem Radialgeschwindigkeiten, wo man eben eine Bestätigung braucht und auch vor allem einen Radius braucht. Bei Kepler ist eigentlich kann Keops jetzt nicht viel beitragen. Hat,
guten Vorteil gehabt, hat Millionen von Sternen an angeschaut, also über hundert, mehrere hunderttausend mit sehr hoher Kadenz und ich glaube über eine Million im im Gesichtsverhältnis, über mehrere Jahre, dreieinhalb Jahre war, glaube ich, die erste Mission,
und aber es kann natürlich dann per Definition, wie's Konstruiert ist nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt am Himmel anschauen. Und wenn man auf einen kleinen Ausschnitt am Himmel eine Million Sterne angucken möchte, dann sind die natürlich klarerweise nicht sehr hell,
vielleicht zwei helle und in diesen paar Quadratgradler angeschaut hat,
und das ist aber auch gleichzeitig das Problem von Kepler. Kepler hat natürlich war ein unfassbaren Fundus an an Daten geliefert für für Excel-Planeten,
und Statistik ist immer noch die absolut größte Quelle, aber die meisten sind eben aufgrund dessen, dass ein Feld angeschaut wurde und später mit Keplern mehrere Felder, aber im wesentlichen war's optimiert auf dunkle Sterne. Das heißt, so elfte bis 16te Größe.
Astronomisch gesprochen. Da kommt einfach nicht, ist einfach unmöglich einen Radialgeschwindigkeitsmessung von einem erdähnlichen Planeten bei der 16. Größe zu machen.
Dreihundert Nächte investiert, dann schafft man's vielleicht in speziell Spezialfällen, aber man kann das nicht nicht ständig tun und da kommt eben dann Keops ins Spiel.
Wir können dann einfach helle Sterne anschauen, die eben,
da in der Regel eben nicht von Kepler entdeckt wurden, aber zum Beispiel von Tess oder eben oder eben Radialgeschwindigkeiten, wo wir wissen, ist ein Planet. Schauen wir doch mal nach, ob er einen Transit macht,
das war die Idee von Keops.
Okay, also man wollte halt quasi eine Lücke füllen im Beobachtungs äh
Weltlauf, weil die ganze Disziplin ist ja noch relativ neu. Man weiß zwar jetzt schon so einiges, aber im Prinzip ist es ja so eine der Felder eigentlich derzeit in der Astronomie, wo man sagen kann, da ist noch am meisten zu holen in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das schnelle wachsendste Gebiet würde ich sagen der Wissenschaft.
Mhm. Letztendlich nicht so einfach, wenn man sich mal ausgedacht hat, man müsste das mal machen, so was dann auch wirklich ins All zu bekommen. wie ist denn wie ist es denn dazu gekommen? Also Cross ja auch eine ganze Menge Geld.
Ja also zuerst gab's ja noch keine S-Klasse Mission von der ESA. Da war dann mal die Idee, was könnte man denn auf die Beine stellen und,
und die Überlegung war mit der Schweiz, Schweden und Österreich,
mal zu schauen, was kann man denn zu dritt auf die Beine stellen für so eine kleine Mission. Mal größere Länder wie Deutschland, Frankreich haben ja regelmäßig,
Nationale Weltraummission, aber für die Schweiz ist das jetzt sozusagen im wissenschaftlichen Sinne das erste Mal und da haben wir halt angefangen eine was macht man? Man macht eine Machbarkeitsstudie, haben halt Finanzierung bekommen, nicht viel einfach ein bisschen Gehälter, um dran zu arbeiten,
um einfach mal,
Glaube es war ein Jahr lang haben wir halt mit Ingenieuren hier wären wir sehr gute Leute im Institut die die was Instrumentenbau angeht immer geschaut,
was kostet das? Was kann das technisch auch mit Partnern geschaut, halt die Spezialisten aus den verschiedenen Gebieten,
natürlich mit den Wissenschaftlern was muss es können und dann war da schnell klar, dass wir so eine größere 20 Parts per Million, also,
wenn die Erde einen Transit macht vor einem sonnenähnlichen Stern, macht ihn eine Verdunkelung von 100 PPM parts per Million, also,
noch minus vier ist die Verdunklung. Also genau sind's ungefähr,
achtzig PPM, das heißt, wenn man das mit einem gewissen Signal Rauschverhältnis messen möchte, möchte man mindestens fünfmal besser sein als Hund, also sagen wir mal 20 Pats per Million, war das,
das Requirement.
Die Verdunkelung misst man in parts per milion.
Deswegen Weltraum, weil man am Boden kann man das ja auch machen. Man kann natürlich eine Lichtkurve aufnehmen vom Boden, aber nimmt einfach jede Minute ein Bild und und extrahiert dann den Fluss. Aber damals hat man so vom Boden typischerweise einen tausendstel geschafft.
Also ein also tausend parts per Million und vielleicht in Supernächten ein super Standort nochmal 500 PPM,
Heute schafft man so vielleicht manchmal, wenn man wirklich gutes 250 PPM vom Boden,
aber wenn man besser werden will, muss man ins All gehen, weil die Atmosphäre einfach zu unkonstant ist.
Mhm, also auch mit den großen Teleskopen in der Atacama.
Es nützt nichts die Größe, weil die hellen Sterne machen so viel Licht, die kann man mit den großen Teleskopen teilweise gar nicht beobachten, weil die zu hell sind.
Und aber für die Schwankungen nützt die Größe des Spiegels eigentlich nichts.
Ein bisschen was wegen dem aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn die Atmosphäre dann eine Wolke durchzieht, selbst eine unsichtbare, einfach eine höhere Wassergehalt als gerade eben.
Hm
Dann schwankt das schnell mal ein paar hundert PPM.
Also muss man ins All. Okay, aber es war schwierig, das zu finanzieren.
Ja, das da war ich an der Finanzierung war ich nicht beteiligt. Irgendwann war das mal finanziert mit der Machbarkeitsstudie, haben wir Geld bekommen, auch von Ruhaxpace, die hier,
eigentlich die größte Space-Firma in der Schweiz ist. und also und vom,
vom Ministerium SBFE also Forschungsgelder geben einfach mal ein bisschen Geld, um mal ein bisschen konkreter zu schauen wer das machbar und am Ende kam raus machbar aber,
schwierig für das Budget, was wir hatten und wir hatten auch noch überlegt infrarot, also die ursprüngliche Idee war,
Sowohl im Infraroten als auch im optischen zu beobachten und ein Strahlteiler zu benutzen auf zwei Detektoren, ein Info-Rotdetetektor und eine CCD-Kamera.
Klassisch wie früher in der Spiegelreflex-Digitalkamera war. Gleichzeitig, weil als würde er noch mehr Informationen geben und da war dann aber relativ schnell klar, dass das wahrscheinlich zu teuer ist mit dem Infrarot.
Ja und das war dann der Stand wo ESA die Ausschreibung gemacht hat plötzlich jetzt für eine S-Klasse Mission.
Und S-Klasse ist so ein beschleunigtes Programm.
Genau, also normal gibt's ja in der ESA eigentlich zwei Typen Formission, gibt die M-Klass, also im medium und die L-Class und Ella ist einfach large und M einfach vom finanziellen Möglichkeiten,
Also meistens sind das so eine,
500 Millionen, glaube ich, ist eine und zwei, 300 Millionen, je nachdem ist eine M-Class-Mission, wobei das meistens der Esar-Beitrag ist, aber es gibt ja dann auch noch Beiträge von den Ländern, die Instrumente finanzieren und so weiter.
Und S-Klass war eben neu und hieß einfach, Eser zahlt 50 Millionen Cost Capt, also maximaler Beitrag,
schlagt mal was vor, so ungefähr.
Der Rest muss von irgendwo anders herkommen.
Das haben wir dann eben gemacht. Wir waren natürlich gut vorbereitet. Wir hatten gerade ein Jahr lang gemacht, also Machbarkeitsstudie.
Und dann war technisch eigentlich klar, was wir wollen, aber natürlich muss man's dann,
hatte ein halbes sechs Monate glaube ich Zeit für die vom Call bis zur Eingabe des,
und das ging relativ schnell und dann hatten sie ja ich glaube zwei achtzehn oder zwanzig Eingaben und uns haben sie dann ausgewählt.
Das ist sicherlich ein Feiertag gewesen hier, oder?
Ja, das war war gut.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen. und wie läuft das dann ab? Also wer wer also wer war dann letzten Endes beteiligt außer der Esar?
Ja zunächst einmal ein großer Teil des Antragsschreiben. Es war auch erstmal rauszufinden, wer alles mitmacht, weil wir hatten ja vorher wirklich ja gesagt, Schweden, Österreich, Schweiz.
Aber man kann keine Eselmission mit drei Ländern machen, am Ende müssen alle 22 sind's glaube ich Eser Mitgliedsstaaten auch zustimmen.
In einer Mehrheitsentscheid, auch wenn's keine teure Mission ist, will ja jeder was davon haben sozusagen,
und am Ende waren wir dann elf Länder plus Esa.
Also und die muss man natürlich alle an einen Tisch kriegen. Uns hat's dann auch ein paar Mal eine Umschichtung gegeben, war mal Anfang welche zugesagt haben. Aber dann,
Andere Missionen noch gerade am werden oder nicht werden, dann wird plötzlich eine Mission ausgewählt, die niemand erwartet hat. Bei den Emissionen zum Beispiel und dann sagt ein Land plötzlich, oh, jetzt brauchen wir das ganze Geld für die Emission, wir haben kein Geld mehr für die Essenmission.
Und dann gab's noch ein paar Unterschiede. Aber jetzt sind so die Hauptländer sind eben Schweiz natürlich als Co-Leitung mit der ESA,
dann ganz wichtiger Beitrag von Spanien, die die Bodenstation zur Verfügung stellen, was sehr untypisch ist für die ist aber eigentlich die Esa immer die Bodenstation stellt, aber das wäre einfach zu teuer gewesen,
und Italien hat die Optik designt und gebaut und eingebaut in die mechanische Struktur, mechanische Struktur des Teleskops haben wir gebaut.
Und alles getestet und kalibriert et cetera aber aber das Teleskop war die optischen Elemente kommen von von Italien,
Deutschland war noch sehr wichtig, die haben die ganze quasi die Kamera gebaut, also die Vokalebene mit dem Detektor die Ausleseelektronik, die super stabile Spannungsversorgung, also eigentlich das,
Herzstück.
Wer ist das, wenn man sagt, Deutschland hat es gebaut in Italien das.
DLR Berlin hat es gebaut.
Und tja und dann gibt's noch eine Reihe andere, also die Belgier haben den den Buffet, also das ist quasi die Streulichtblende vorne gebaut, die sieht man schon für Coro gebaut hatten, natürlich angepasst und auch der Deckel, man hat einen Deckel,
nur das ganze Instrument vor Dreck schützt, bis es aus der Rakete draußen ist und wo wundert es immer unser einziger Mechanismus. Also es muss dann auch aufgehen, wenn's oben ist.
Und,
Ja, Frankreich hat Bodensegment für die Datenreduktion mitgearbeitet, England ebenfalls Schweden ist immer noch dabei. Sie helfen auch bei Datenauswertung.
Habe ich jetzt jemanden vergessen.
Ungarn haben die Radiatoren gebaut, also die die muss die Wärme wegkriegen und kühlt. Wir können ja Detektor auf Minus 45 Grad passiv. Ähm.
Also nur durch Wärmeableitung. Mhm.
Wärme ab, Wärmeableitung, genau. Ja und vom Consortium.
Das klingt aber jetzt echt aufwendig, also das alles zu koordinieren, das wird am Ende auch ein funktionierender Apparat dabei rauskommt und auch permanent so viele Gruppen in Synk zu halten. Ist das nicht total schwierig? Das ist dann hier gemacht.
Also das ist hier gemacht worden, ja. Ich habe hier geleitet die Mission und ich hatte dann Hilfe von einem Instrumentmanager,
Managerin, die wir schon nie, die sich dann halt hauptsächlich ums Instrument gekümmert hat. Aber wir waren ja nicht nur fürs Instrument zuständig. Ich war eben auch für die ganze Bodensegment ganze da ganze ganze Zock heißt das Science Operation Center in Genf zuständig,
und ja das war schon die Koordination war schon Hauptaufgabe. Man muss ja dann Spezifikationen schreiben und muss die dann runterbrechen auf die Subsysteme und die ganzen Schnittstellen müssen ja alle stimmen. Das heißt wenn die Teile hier ankommen, dass die dann auch zusammenpassen und,
das ist noch das Einfachere auch zusammen funktionieren,
Es war schon damals gemerkt, es war eine kleine Mission, aber die Schnittstellen waren genauso fast genauso kompliziert wie bei einer M-Klassemission.
Gleich noch eine größere machen können. 290 Kilogramm wiegt der gesamte Satellit, das ist ja jetzt für Größenordnung nicht so viel.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht alleine an Bord der Rakete gewesen, oder?
Ja genau, also es war von Anfang an dann waren's klar, schon zur Zeit der Machbarkeitsstudie, dass wir uns keine eigene Rakete leisten können,
Gab immer wieder mal Gerüchte, dass die Schweden haben mal einen Satelliten, Odin hieß der mit irgendeiner alten russischen Atomintercontinentalrakete hochgeschossen für irgendwie zwei Millionen Dollar. Aber die Zeiten waren vorbei.
Mhm. Aber die Zeiten waren vorbei.
Quasi, die haben's quasi nur bevor es irgendwie das Verfallsdatum der Rakete abläuft, haben sie sich noch ist dann einfach irgendwo hingefahren oder Kette hoch und abgeschossen irgendwo aufm Feld,
Aber wenn man eine normale Rakete kaufen muss, dann ist es so teuer. Das sprengt total unser Budget. Und deswegen war von Anfang an klar, dass wir als sogenannter Ride irgendwo mitfliegen.
Und dann zahlt man nach Gewicht meistens. Also wenn jetzt sagen wir mal der Launcher zwei Tonnen ins niedrigen Erdomlaufbahn befördern kann und er wiegt aber nur 300 Kilo, dann zahlt man und der andere ist der vielleicht 1,5 Tonnen.
Zahlt man halt nur ein Fünftel oder so vom Preis und das ist dann schon wird dann langsam erschwinglicher.
Wie findet man da so seinen Ride? Gibt's da gibt's da eine App für oder wen ruft.
Nein, das war sehr schwierig. Also ich meine, als wir es dann mit der ESA gemacht haben, wir konnten uns ja dann aussuchen in dem Art Proposal, wer macht was und wir haben ja gesagt, Esa macht macht ihr mal Launch, sucht ihr uns mal einen eine Rakete? und bezahlt auch dafür. Also das war das war sozusagen,
Teil zusammen auch natürlich mit der Plattform, also wir haben die den Satellit eigentlich in Auftrag gegeben, was dann am Ende Airbus Spanien gebaut hat,
und die hatten ziemlich zu kämpfen. Also wir wir wollten ja nicht irgendwo hin,
Wir wollten ja in eine niedrige Erdumlaufbahn. Wir wussten auch, dass wir zwischen 600 und 800 Kilometer Höhe müssen und dass wir einen sogenannten Sonnensynkronen-Arbeit müssen. Das heißt,
normalerweise wenn ein Orbit um die Erde sich dreht, ist der fix und die Erde dreht sich aber um die Sonne, das heißt die Richtung der Sonne zum Orbit ändert sich über das Jahr.
Und es war wär aber für uns nicht gut gewesen, weil dann wäre die Sonne immer mal von der einen, mal von der anderen Seite gekommen. Wir wären mal in Erdschatten gekommen, was gar nicht gut ist für die Temperatur stabilisierung.
Und da haben wir relativ schnell kam nicht wochenlang ich monatelange Studien aber unser endgültiger Orbit war dann eben sonnensynchron. Das heißt man kann den Orbit so machen, dass er sich wie ein Gyroskop mitdreht oder wie einen wie ein Kreisel wie ein Kinderkreisel.
Gestern über die Pole oder? Mhm.
Sie haben einen Polar Orbit SSO nennt sich's nennt man Sunsynce ORBIT, wo man einfach nicht so eine Neigung einstellt, dass eben nicht genau über die Pulle geht, sondern.
So ein bisschen dran vorbei.
Weil die Erde eben nicht rund ist, sondern so ein bisschen so ein Donut oder bisschen so eine zerdrückte Kartoffel gibt's eben dann Drehmomente auf diesen Kreisel und dann dreht's fährt der Kreisel an zu drehen,
doch die Neigung der Bahn kann man die Geschwindigkeit der Rotation also die Präzisionsgeschwindigkeit quasi setzen und man man macht halt so das sind 365 Tagen einmal rundum dreht,
Synchron.
Sonnensyndron und man hat die Sonne immer von derselben.
Das machen viele Satelliten, auch die deswegen waren unsere Hoffnung, dass wir mit einem also wir sind auf sechs Uhr, dann kann man durch die Uhrzeit einstellen, wann wenn man jetzt zwölf Uhr immer über die übern Horizont kommen oder,
oder morgens um sechs oder mittags um zehn, also die ganzen Radar-Sattelliten hat sich da rausgestellt, fliegen wir morgens um zehn weil.
Über den Pool oder über die.
Oder kommen dann über den über den Äquator hoch sozusagen. So ist es definiert, diese local time of the exanding Note.
Über Äquator, alles klar. Mhm.
Sie stehen immer dann ganzen Tag, der Orbit bleibt sozusagen und dort wo die Uhrzeit zehn Uhr ist, ist immer der Orbit und in einer Stunde ist man herum oder in in Stunde, zwanzig Minuten,
und weil die halt immer Sonne brauchen, das heißt die wollen halt auch die Sonne von hinten haben. Wenn sie optisch beobachten, ist es um halb 11 Uhr am morgens am wenigsten Wolkenbedeckung, deswegen fliegen die alle um halb elf,
Es hat uns war aber für uns nicht gut, wir brauchten sechs Uhr, das heißt wir haben also einen Radar Satelliten gesucht, der auch um sechs Uhr morgens fliegt, weil da hat man den Vorteil, dass man immer die Sonne im Rücken hat, immer volle Power. Und Rad aus der dritten brauchen halt viel Strom.
War dann nicht so leicht einzufinden. Die Es hat ganz schön schwitzen müssen, bis sie uns dann einen mit Flug gefunden haben.
Man kann nicht einfach jetzt bei irgendeinem anderen Satelliten mitfliegen, der wo jetzt grad nochmal Platz ist, sondern es muss halt im Prinzip ein ähnlicher Orbit sein bis hin zu dieser Feineinstellung, damit das irgendwie passt.
Ja, es muss fast genau der gleiche Orbit sein, also,
man kann dann schon noch korrigieren. Also die Höhe muss nicht genau dieselbe sein oder so. Also in unserem Fall war es sogar so, dass wir dann gestartet sind letzten Endes mit einem italienischen Erdbeobachtungsattelliten Radar und optisch.
Halb Militärisch, halb Zivil und noch mit drei kleineren Satelliten und Kubsatz.
Und wir sind ja mit der Sojus gestartet. Es und dann und und die Oberstufe war die Fregatte. Das,
und die kann Sachen, die nicht jeder Launcher kann, also der hat es dann gestartet, hat den Hauptpassagier, also den italienischen Riesensatelliten mit knapp zwei Tonnen auf seiner Höhe ausgesetzt. Ich weiß es nicht mehr auswendig, ich sage jetzt mal bei,
achthundert Kilometer,
Hat er es dann wieder runtergegangen, hat den Lange Adapter abgeworfen, damit er in der Atmosphäre verglüht, ist wieder hochgegangen, also so von 400 Kilometer auf unsere siebenhundert Kilometer, hat uns ausgesetzt,
und du kannst zwischendrin immer wieder das Drehwerk ausgeschaltet eben und dann nachdem uns ausgesetzt hatte, hat er dann noch die anderen zwei Kleinstatiliten ausgesetzt und dann noch die Cubes hats. Alle auf einer anderen Höhe. Aber was man eben nicht ändern kann, ist die Intonation.
Oder die Uhrzeit, weil dafür braucht man wahnsinnig viel Sprit. Also schon die Höhe braucht schon Sprit, aber wenn man halt,
eher leichter ist als der Launcherschaft, dann hat er halt noch ein bisschen und es war war aber nicht so ganz die gewöhnliche Sache, dass der so viele Manöver gemacht hat, diese Fregadoberstufe.
Und auch so ein Höhenunterschied auch ausgleichen muss, ja. Klingt jetzt noch relativ viel. Ähm
Sojus, aber nicht in Russland gestartet, sondern in Koro
In Französisch-Guyana. Da gibt es ja seit einiger Zeit nicht eben nur die Ariane, sondern eben auch noch einen Startplatz für eine an den Standort angepasste Sojus
und einem die italienische WEGA Rakete gibt's ja jetzt mittlerweile auch noch, die kann man aber nicht in Frage.
Nein, die Wäger kamen nicht. Ich meine, man muss eben auch einen einen Passagier finden, der wo man mitfliegen kann,
Ist auch ein bisschen ich glaube die war auch ein bisschen schwächer, das heißt muss ja dann noch Platz sein,
Also wir haben eigentlich von Anfang an haben wir designt, muss ja jedes jede Paket ist ja anders, was die Vibrationen angeht. Es gibt zwei Sachen, es gibt die Vibrationen vom sage ich jetzt mal vom Raketenantrieb,
gibt's den Schock von der Separation der Stufen und beides ist muss im Design des Instruments berücksichtigt werden. Also es nützt nichts, wenn man in Vibration überlebt und dann beim Absprengen der Stufe einem der Spiegel zerspringt.
Wir haben von Anfang an ja gewusst, wir können's uns nicht aussuchen. Also wir haben Designt für Vega, für Sojus und für Falcon nein. unser Design Parameter,
Falko nein war uns immer klar, dass die Essa das nur ungern macht mit einer amerikanischen Rakete zu starten. Wozu hat man die eigenen,
Aber aber man musste eben dafür designen und wir haben die relativ und ganz am Anfang hatten wir noch die PSLV, die indische. Die konnten wir dann zum Glück irgendwann mal,
lassen, weil die sehr laut ist. Also im gewissen Spektralbereich ist die war die relativ schwierig von den Spezifikationen.
Laut beim Start.
Also laut heißt einfach, dass die Vibration sehr große Amplitude haben.
Mhm. Okay, das heißt es war dann klar, Sojus hat man dann
wie läuft denn das eigentlich mit der Sojus in Guyana? Ist das alles unter der Ägide der Eser oder ist man dann auch mit den Russen direkt in Kommunikation wie.
Nein, also das ist muss man sich bisschen vorstellen wie eine russische Enklave.
Wo das fahren die also gibt's dann ein Kontrollzentrum wo die Russen sitzen, die die einen, die die Rakete steuern, die anderen, die die die Oberstufe steuern.
Sitzt nochmal woanders im Hauptkontrollzentrum bekommt ihr Information, aber es ist wirklich eine relativ russische Geschichte.
Okay, das heißt, sie haben da noch ein eigenes Startkontrollzentrum, so wie ja auch Arianes Bass nochmal ein eigenes Startzentrum hat, unabhängig von dem eigentlichen Kontrollzentrum für alle Starts, wo alle sitzen und,
dass es funktioniert. Ich war mal da, da habe ich mir das mal angeschaut, aber bei den Russen war ich nicht. Ähm,
Okay und muss man viel mit denen kommunizieren?
Also wir jetzt nicht, weil's ja war ja Verantwortung den Staat zu organisieren. Das heißt das ESA-Projektteam war da schon öfter unten. Vor allem dann in der,
letzten Phase, wo die wo dann das die letzten Tests gemacht werden und irgendwann muss ja auch unser Satellit auf diesen Adapter montiert werden,
das also die Nutzlastverkleidung angebracht werden und,
In diesem Fall gibt's ein sogenanntes ASUPS, das ist wie so ein Käfig, den man drüber setzt, wo dann oben drauf der Hauptpassagier sitzen kann.
Wird man sie der Reihe nach dann abwerfen kann.
Man sie der Reihe nach dann abwerfen kann und daher gibt's schon relativ viel, glaube ich, Kontakt, aber wie gesagt, es war jetzt nicht unser Verantwortungsbereich.
Okay, das kriegt man dann einfach als als Service sozusagen oben drauf. Der Start war dann am 18. Dezember 219 und hat offensichtlich gut funktioniert.
Gut funktioniert. Gab einen Tag Verzögerung, war noch recht spannend, also wir mussten halt immer ein bisschen runter. Wir durften runter fliegen und zuschauen.
War mein erster Start mein einziger bis jetzt.
immerhin.
War aufregend, aber am Anfang hat's nicht funktioniert. Sie muss dann so, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, um zwei Uhr auf morgens aufstehen. Wenn wir mal um sechs Uhr,
morgens local time of the sending, Nordart heißt das der Start auch ungefähr um sechs Uhr morgens ist, also so um fünf Uhr vierzig oder so, Ortszeit war das und,
man musste dann irgendwann drei Stunden vorher dort sein. Fährt er mit dem Bus rausgekarrt in den Urwald dort und ja dann waren wir noch im Bus und dann hieß es, Start Abbruch.
Der Computer, der hat irgendwie so ein Konditionsfehler gemeldet. Hat irgendwie.
Dann ist man sofort Schluss.
Sofort Schluss und und wir hatten schon gedacht, oh je, also ich dachte persönlich schon, ich fliege morgen wieder heim, weil unverrichteter Dinge,
Man kann die nur, ich weiß nicht mehr die Zeit, ich glaube acht Stunden lang kann man die betankt lassen, dann muss man den Treibstoff abpumpen.
Dann dauert's wieder.
Dann dauert's wieder, weil die sind ja die fliegen ja mit Kerosin, die die aber brauchen ja dann Flüssigsauerstoff. Und der ist sehr kalt, der hält kann man ja nicht ewig,
drin lassen und dann da wenn man das den Fehler nicht findet also irgendwie hat wohl die Zeit Synchronisation zwischen dem Computer und der Bodenstation nicht funktioniert,
aber die Russen sind halt zwar ich glaube 3zwanzigste Flug von,
Französisch-Kujana, aber wahrscheinlich der, was ist die Zahl nicht? Da war der hundertste Flug oder mehr von überhaupt der Sojus heißt die wussten was sie tun,
Die haben dann aus meiner Sicht das Undenkbare gemacht. Die sind haben die die Rakete enttankt, also nur den Sauerstoff.
Alles innerhalb von 24 Stunden sind hochgeklettert, haben irgendeinen Kappe a Schraube ab, paar Schrauben abgeschraubt, haben zwei Platinen rausgezogen, neue Platinen reingesteckt, die da zugeschraubt. Systemcheck, am nächsten Tag ging's los.
Die machen das ja auch schon eine Weil.
Muss das aber sich so vorstellen, normalerweise bei einem Weltraum also bedeutet bei uns im Instrument, wenn man da eine Platine austauschen würde, würde das so funktionieren, man macht die Kiste auf, die ist aber geklebt zu der zusätzlichen Schrauben,
nimmt man die raus, baut die wieder ein,
klebt die wieder, macht die wieder zu und dann muss mindestens nochmal einen qualifizierender Delta-Qualifikationsvibrationstest stattfinden, um zu checken, dass alles geht und mit nachträglichen funktionalen Test,
Das dauert und das kann man ja auf einer Rakete sowieso nicht machen. Müsste man sie alles wieder runternehmen von der Rakete.
Nur die Rosen sind da einfach ganz on und sagen, haben wir schon zehn Mal gemacht, passt schon.
Hat alles geklappt ja und am Ende perfekt geklappt. Also wir mussten nicht mal ein Orbit Korrekturmanöver fliegen.
Ähm,
Was mir mal interessieren würde ist, was ist denn eigentlich drin in so einem Satelliten? Wie wie ist der so aufgebaut? Was was,
an was für Komponenten muss man denken. Klar, man hat jetzt so das eigentliche Instrument und die Optik und den Spiegel und die entsprechenden Klappen, die sich öffnen und schließen müssen. Aber die ganze Kommunikation dieser einzelnen Teile ineinander, wie ist das organisiert? Was für ein Aufwand wird da getrieben in so einem
Gerät, wie komplex ist das.
Ja es ist eigentlich relativ simpel was die Kommunikation angeht aber ich meine was muss in einem Satelliten drin sein, also muss die Plattform muss dann erstmal mit Strom versorgen, also normalerweise in einem Erdumlaufband sind das Solarpanels,
bei allen Missionen, außer wenn man mal zu Udonus rausfliegt, dann geht das nicht mehr.
Dann braucht man Atomreaktoren, mhm.
Ja nicht Reaktoren dann meistens so radioaktive Thermo-Nuklear-Devices, also die die durch die Wärme doch zerfallen einfach Strom erzeugen.
Aber sonst sind's einfach Solarzellen, dann halt irgendwie ein Power Converte, der einem die die Spannung oder die Spannungen nennen, die man so braucht halt aus den unregulierten 32 irgendwie also jetzt mal 21 bis 34 Volt Solarzellenstrom liefert,
und dann natürlich die der Board Computer, also der das die Plattform steuert,
und die mechanische Stabilität, die ganze Struktur muss man bauen natürlich, wo man dann auch die Instrumente montiert sind. dann braucht man irgendeinen Antrieb,
in unserem Fall eigentlich nur im Weltraum Weltraumstrott ausweichen zu können und am Schluss wieder die Orbiting machen zu können, also um den nicht noch selbste Weltraumschrott zu werden am Ende der Lebensdauer.
Wichtig.
und dann ganz wichtig die Lageregelung und es wird eigentlich in der Regel mit sogenannten Reaction-Weels, also mit Schwungrädern gemacht,
in der Regel mit vier Stück. Drei braucht man, eins, für jede Achse und ein viertes aus.
Resultanz gründen.
Redondanz und da muss man sich so vorstellen, wie der Eisläufer, der die Arme anzieht und dann schneller wird. Er wird auch Drehmpulserhaltung.
Kann ich wenn ich im Raumschiff bin und fange an irgendwie ein,
ein Gyroskop hoch zu beschleunigen. Dann fängt das Satellit an in die andere Richtung zu drehen. Und so kann man halt in alle Richtungen den Satellit wenden und neigen, wie man will.
Jeder, der schon mal so ein Fahrrad in der Hand gehalten hat, was wo das Rad sich dreht und die Bewegung macht, kann man sich die Kräfte ganz gut.
Oder Motorradfahrer, der Sprünge macht und mit Gashebel sozusagen die Vorderrad hoch und senken kann, das ist das Gleiche.
Mhm. Das Gleiche. Mhm.
Und tja und dann gibt's noch bei uns im Fall gibt's noch Magnet,
heißen die, also Magnetfeld Sensoren aber auch starke Elektromagneten in dem man,
da kann man dann das Erdmagnetfeld ausnutzen, um auch einen Drehmoment zu erzeugen. Weil weil diese Schwungräder, die würden immer schneller und schneller und schneller sein, weil zum Beispiel,
Luftwiderstand oder irgendwelche Effekte sind meistens nicht immer genau symmetrisch verteilt, sondern neigen dazu den Salitten immer die gleiche Richtung zu drehen,
Wenn es Schwungrad immer die gleiche Richtung ausdrehen korrigieren muss, wird's immer schneller und schneller und schneller, dann muss man die immer wieder entladen, sagt man dem. Und das kann man entweder mit,
Raketendüsen Düsen machen. Da braucht man aber Treibstoff oder man kann's eben mit Magnet Drehmoment am Magnetfeld machen und wir machen's mit Magnetfeld, dann braucht man überhaupt gar keinen Treibstoff.
Magnetfeld der Erde.
Wir sind in einem niedrigen Orbit, siebenhundert Kilometer. Also er hat sechstausend Kilometer Radius. Also siebenhundert Kilometer ist nicht sehr hoch. Noch voll im Erdmagnetfeld und kann sich da quasi festhalten.
Man bremst sozusagen die Räder mit dem Magnetfeld der Erde ab. Wow. Nicht gedacht, dass das geht. Diese ganze Plattform muss man da alles neu erfinden oder gibt's da irgendwas, worauf man aufbauen kann?
Nein, es gibt also in unserem Fall haben wir es wurde eine Ausschreibung gemacht und der Sieger der Ausschreibung war am Schluss Airbus Spanien und die haben das sogenannte AS zweihundertfuffzig Plattformen,
Ungefähr 250 Kilogramm, weiß nicht ganz stimmt. Also wir waren noch ein bisschen größer als wir gebraucht hätten und die haben sie dann im Wesentlichen genommen und verkleinert,
weil wir hatten eben Spezifikationen, dass wir als Passagier in die eben in diese Passagier,
Sagen Löcher auf der Rakete passen müssen.
Waren die eine Standardplattform in der Regel zu groß und deswegen mussten wir uns so ein bisschen verkleinern, wir mussten auch andere Schwungräder verwendet werden als eigentlich gedacht, weil die eben zu groß waren und paar Komponenten getauscht und im Großen und Ganzen ist das eine existierende Plattform, das heißt die ganze,
ganze Software vor allem die ganze Computertechnik, die ganze Redundanz von dem ganzen System,
antrieb war vorhanden und muss halt angepasst werden aufs aufs konkrete Nutzung, aber es ist jetzt nicht, dass sie einen neuen Satelliten vom Reißplatz.
Ist das dieses Astro-Bus-System, was da zum Einsatz kommt. So heißt das.
Mhm. So ist das. Also A ist zwo for fifty ist das Astropost. Ich möchte jetzt nicht mit Astrium verwechsle.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist dasselbe, ja.
Mhm. Okay, also man hat quasi so einen Baukasten, wo man womit man mal schon mal arbeiten kann. Also man muss jetzt nicht wirklich Satelliten neu erfinden, sondern,
man man man greift da einfach auf eine bestehende Technik, sucht sich was in der passenden Größenordnung. Jetzt waren wir bei 29 Kilo, 25 passt noch ein bisschen mit ein paar Anpassungen und dann kann man im Prinzip,
seine Konzentration auch auf das stecken, worauf man wo man ja auch die Expertise hat. Also
et cetera, Datenkommunikation muss man dann komplett selber machen oder wird das dann auch schon so teilweise abgenommen.
Datenkommunikation funktioniert oft auch in unserem Fall über sogenanntes Push-System, also,
POS, also wofür steht das jetzt? Paket irgendwas System, also man schickt Datenpakete, die halt standardisiert sind, gibt's eine gibt's einen Standard, die eigentliche Leitung, über die die geschickt werden, gibt verschiedene. Also wir kommunizieren jetzt mitm Raumschiff, über den sogenannten Milchstandard.
Ein militärischer Bus,
Neuer wäre Space Wire, da kommunizieren wir mit unserer Kamera intern und am Ende werden aber sogenannte Puss-Pakete geschickt, die immer so funktionieren. Man schickt immer ein Telekommando.
Zum Beispiel kann das Telekommando sein, ladet die Applikationssoftware und dann antwortet das andere Gerät mit einem,
gibt's verschiedene eben, alles in Ordnung, Befehl abgelehnt, Befehl geschlagen, Befehl ausgeführt, kommen wieder so Statuspakete zurück,
Es gibt auch sogenannte Housekeeping-Pakete, die man einstellen kann, zum Beispiel alle 60 Sekunden kommt ein Paket mit so,
Daten, Informationen, Gesundheitszustand, nenne ich's jetzt mal, des des Instruments, die auch über diesen über diesen Bus Format gesendet werden. In unserem Fall werden die dann zum Raumschiff gesendet. Das Raumschiff hat einen Speicher.
Er weiß einfach die Pakete vom Instrument, gerade in Speicher drei und da speichert er die ab. Und jedes Mal, wenn wieder Bodenkontakt ist,
Werden die schickte Boden, Kommandos Signal, schickt mir alles, was du neu im Speicher hast und dann werden die runter runtergeschickt und dann gelöscht oder zyklisch überschrieben in unserem Fall.
Genau und die Bodenkommunikation war dann immer über Spanien mit den Bodenstationen dort,
Gut, also ich Kiob sagt man, ne? Kieops, Chios, Riops, wie man möchte. Ähm,
Der Start ist gelungen. Das Ding hat sein Orbit gefunden. Dann dieser Sonnensynchrone.
700 Kilometer hoch war das dann in etwa, ne? Und ja dann muss man ja erstmal so ein bisschen alles in Betrieb nehmen und testen. Das hat alles gut funktioniert.
Hat super funktioniert, also als allererstes ja, man muss ja mal Kontakt bekommen. Das Erste nennt sich immer Liop, muss ich überlegen, wo die Abkreuzung steht, low earth orbit.
launch and early orbit face so ja. Und also in dieser early obits wird's erstes Mal das Enttaumeln der Plattform, weil die,
Versuche zwar den den die Rakete so zu entwickeln, dass die den möglichst Drehmoment frei rausspickt, aber ein bisschen dreht sich's immer,
das hat unsere Plattform autonom gemacht soeben durch diese Elektromagnete doch eine bestimmte Konfliktation kann man so machen, dass sie sich dann,
Erdmagnetfeld automatisch Sonnengerichtet aus taumelt, hat auch funktioniert,
Und dann haben wir zwei sogenannte S-Bahn-Antennen, die quasi direkt zu nah sind. Die eine deckt die eine Halbkugel und die andere die andere Halbkugel ab, so dass man eigentlich immer Kontakt haben müsste, wenn man in Sichtweite der Bodenstation ist.
Hat's schon beim ersten Versuch auf Antarktika hatten wir eine Station gemietet da hat schon gleich die Kommunikationsaufnahme funktioniert,
wussten wir schon, es lebt.
Also Bilderbuchstaat.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Kann man sagen. Okay, super.
Dann kamen vier, fünf Tage Leop, also launch and early obit face von Airbus. Das war die Verantwortung von Airbus, die die Plattform geliefert haben,
die waren dann am an unserem Mock in Spanien, aber aber es war nicht unsere Mockopperators verantwortlich, sondern die Mission Operation Center,
also die Bodenstation, was sonst eh Sock in Darmstadt für die Esar machen würde,
aber da hatte die Hauptverantwortung als als Hersteller der Plattform und da waren die Leute von Airbus vor Ort und unsere Leute waren auch vor Ort um die Befehle zu schicken,
aber jeden hat quasi der Chef von dem Entwicklungsteam von Airbus sozusagen abgesegnet,
machen die halt so Checks erstmal alle einzelnen Komponenten hochfahren. Also manches klar der Computer läuft. Sobald es die Rakete startet, einen rausschmeißt, wird der wird der gestartet.
Und,
aber so die ganzen Peripherie zu starten und zu schauen, das Erste, was wichtig ist, wären die Batterien geladen sind, funktionieren die Solarpanels. Weil da hat man nur weiß nicht wie viel Stunden Zeit, ein paar Umläufe, dann geht langsam die Batterie aus.
Und das und wenn die kritischen Sachen dann gehen, dann wird eigentlich nur so checks die ganze volle funktionale es gibt so full functional Test, wo man halt alle elektronischen Komponenten auf Herz und Nieren überprüft, ob alles so funktioniert wie soll.
Eigentlich ein super Service. Man kriegt sozusagen diese Plattform und damit ist dann auch gleich die ganze Inbetriebnahme auch aus der Hand gegeben. Also man kriegt quasi dann so einen.
Von der Plattform, ja? Aber das waren eben nur die paar die ersten paar Tage. also das war jetzt erstmal Leopold, Leop ist wirklich nur so die Grund safety, wenn's dann in einem sogenannten Save-Mode ist, also alles.
Passt. Mhm.
Weihnachten und weil wir in der Mission sind haben wir die Bodenstation nicht für die Feiertage bezahlt. Also war erstmal eine Woche aber abwarten angesagt.
Ob's zu teuer wäre die Leute.
Und dann haben wir im im Januar nach den Feiertagen haben wir begonnen und da waren wir dann auch alle unten vom Instrument und vom vom Science Operation Center.
Vom Instrument-Team und dann ging eigentlich die Inbetriebnahme los und die war in erster Linie Instrument, Inbetriebnahme, also Instrument einschalten, schauen ob's Instrument funktioniert, auch die ganzen Tests machen.
Deckel ja noch zu. erstmal dunkel Bilder aufnehmen. Ähm,
Ja, alle möglichen Modi testen und dann irgendwann natürlich der große Moment Deckel öffnen. Öffnet sich der Deckel.
Und wenn er sich geöffnet hat, sehen wir dann mehr als wir vorher gesehen haben.
Dann haben wir dann endlich dann den Tag funktioniert. Da war natürlich ein großer großer Feier. Ist zwar Triple redundant, sondern Deckel öffnen, aber man weiß ja nie.
Beim Ersten schon funktioniert.
Ab dem ersten funktioniert.
Also drei verschiedene Mechanismen wie man das Ding aufkriegt.
Nicht ganz, aber es gibt es in dem Fall ist so, dass der funktioniert so ist eine vorgespannte Feder, die,
drei Federn, die es vorspannen. Auf der anderen Seite ist ein Bolzen und der Bolzen ist ähm,
sondern wie sagt man dann Memory Shape Alloy, also so einen Gedächtnismetall ist da dran und wenn man dieses Gedächtnis Metall erhitzt, dehnt sich das aus und bricht den Bolzen. Und die uns gab er auch drei Heizer für diesen.
Also Gedächtnis sozusagen anderer anderer Form und durch die Hitze wird diese Form dann wieder angestrebt und sprengt. Mhm. Man drückt ihn dann zusammen. Mhm.
Genau. Also war einfach länger. Man drückt ihn dann zusammen auf eine kürzere Größe und wenn er wieder erhitzt wird.
Länger sein. Das ist der erste Mechanismus. Oder den gibt's dreimal.
Ja das ist nein nein nein ich sage nur die die heizt die die Federn waren dreifach, die Heizer waren dreifach den Mechanismus, den den Bolzen selbst gibt's nur einmal.
Okay, also der hätte schon funktionieren müssen. Hat aber auch funktioniert und dann war der Deckel offen und dann kommt Licht rein und dann ist ja im Prinzip alles ready to run, oder?
Haben dann schon noch einen Monat lang Messungen gemacht. Das ist vor allem Kalibulationsmessungen. Also zunächst mal muss man ja schauen, wo schauen wir hin,
Man hat ja versucht, das Instrument mit Laser-Trackern und und allem drum und dran und und speziellen optischen Würfeln,
Perfekt auszurichten zum Koordinatensystem der Plattform, sodass man sich so vorstellen, dass die Plattform hält ja die Lage und hat seine eigenen Star-Tracker, also seine eigenen kleinen Kameras, wo er sich am Himmel orientiert, wo er schaut,
aber er muss ja wissen, wo das Instrument hinschaut. Unser unser Gesichtfeld ist nicht sehr groß, also im ungefähren Grad.
Und dann muss man den Stern finden, den man angucken möchte und und das heißt das erste war mal ein Bild zu nehmen, aufn Stern zu gucken,
und das zu schauen, dass wir einen richtigen Ort hinschaut,
und du weißt nicht, was wir saßen in in Torachhorn oder also nicht in der Bodenstation, weil es war schon abends. Die Daten kommen dann ja immer abends um 20 Uhr kamen die dann,
wieder über Local time of the sending note sechs Uhr. Das heißt, ihr habt einen Bodenkontakt morgens um sechs. Morgens um vier, morgens um sechs und abends um,
Um fünf und um sieben oder so und bis die Daten dann da waren, war das halt um dann acht Uhr abends.
Saßen wir alle um den Computer und haben das Bild runtergeladen und haben's angeguckt und zwar nicht der Stern, den wir sehen wollten.
Woran erkennt man den Stern, dass es der Richtige ist?
Wir hatten ja so einen einen Video-Astronomen im Teleskop, sondern einen Finding-Chart, wo die verschiedenen Sterne sind. Die man sehen sollte in der Helligkeit und zahlt einfach anders aus. Also es war nicht die gleiche Form von Sternen,
zu suchen ein bisschen größeren Ausschnitt und dann.
Suchen jetzt mit dem Computer suchen oder.
Mit dem menschlichen Hirn ja.
Aha.
Am Anfang und haben da ziemlich schnelle gesehen, wo wir, dass wir halt gerade so außerhalb vom Gesichtsfeld sind.
Es war der einfache Paar, aber da muss man eben ausrechnen auf mehr oder weniger aufm Blatt Papier,
die stand mit Computer dann aber welche in welche Richtung müssen wir das korrigieren, in welche gibt ja drei Möglichkeiten damit wir dann richtig treffen.
Was ich ganz verstehe ist, ich meine wenn da Star-Trecker sind, dann können die doch eigentlich,
die orientieren sich ja quasi am kompletten Sternenfeld, nicht wahr? Die Dinger wissen halt, welche Sterne es gibt und wo die sind und wie die zueinander stehen. Damit müsste doch eigentlich die Ausrichtung schon stimmen. Warum warum guckt ihr dann nicht automatisch in die richtige Richtung?
Ja weil die das ist die Ausrichtung der Star-Tracker stimmt, aber die Star-Trackers sind ja nicht also die wissen ja nicht, das Raumschiff muss ja sozusagen wissen oder gesagt bekommen, genau wie ist der Blickrichtung von unserem Teleskop relativ zu den Star Treckern.
Schauen ja sozusagen so nach links und rechts.
Ja. Und das Teleskop schaut nach vorne. Ja.
Teleskop schaut nach vorne. Und der Winkel, genau muss er genau vermessen sein. In dem Fall besser als ein Grad genau.
Okay, also es geht da um die Auflösung. Also grundsätzlich weiß man natürlich schon.
Um die Auflösung, es geht um das Wissen, wie genau habe ich das Teleskop auf der Plattform festgeschraubt,
oder auch wie genau habe ich's charakterisiert. Im Labor wurden eigentlich die Blickrichtung ist. Also wie beim Feldstecher wo schaut denn der Feldstecher eigentlich genau hin?
Okay. Da kann man sich sozusagen vorher nicht nicht sicher genug sein, wo es wirklich ist. Also in etwa weiß man ja schon, wo man hinguckt. Nur es geht jetzt hier darum.
Genau eben.
Man muss es eben sehr genau machen, okay. So und wie und wie korrigiert man das dann?
Wenn man weiß, in welche Richtung man falsch schaut, dann muss man ja nur dem Raumschiff quasi System ein Offset geben.
Und dann drehen sich die Rädchen und dann guckt er in die richtige Richtung.
Und wir haben's drei verschiedene ausgerechnet wir haben's ausgerechnet und Mock hat's ausgerechnet, haben alle ungefähr das Gleiche rausbekommen im gleichen Vorzeichen und das Wichtigste ist auch aus Vorzeichen.
Das nächste Bild war dann genau in der Mitte.
Okay, gut. Haben alle auch das metrische System benutzt sozusagen. So und das ist dann der Moment, wo es eigentlich losgehen kann.
Ja, fast. Also wir haben ja viele Beobachtungen noch gemacht, so wir müssen ja den Dunkelstrom charakterisieren. Das haben wir mit geschlossenem Deckel gemacht, aber müssen natürlich dann auch schauen, mit offenem Deckel können wir den Dunkelstrom immer noch charakterisieren, aber sie haben die ganze Mission immer weiter machen müssen.
Dunkelstrom ist sozusagen was bekommt man auf die Sensoren wenn's eigentlich dunkel ist. Genau. Um das sozusagen so ein so ein Helligkeitsabgleich, so eine Kalibration vorzunehmen. Mhm.
Und auch die.
Übrigens. Dunkelstrom gefällt mir sehr.
auch die ganzen ja sage mal verschiedene Messmethoden und zu schauen funktioniert das,
stimmt, wenn ich einen hell Stern angucke. Ich weiß, weil ich gucke Alpha Zentauri an. Ich weiß, wie hell der ist. Bekomme ich so viele Photonen, wie ich erwarte.
Hat sich herausgestellt, wir haben 25 Prozent weniger bekommen und nach längerem Studium hat sich dann rausgestellt, dass es ein Fehler in der Kommunikation, im Interface mit den optischen Designern war, die Definition der Fläche,
und,
danach waren's nur noch irgendwie sieben Prozent zu wenig und hat ihnen herausgestellt, die die die Quanteneffizienz des Detektors in absoluten Zahlen ist sehr sehr schwierig zu messen,
War schon immer ein Fragezeichen. Uns kam eine andere Messung vom Hersteller, die ein bisschen anders war als die die ESA gemacht hat und,
gesagt, die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo dazwischen, also dann haben wir gesagt, okay, jetzt noch auch vier Prozent die Quanteneffizient falsch in absoluten Zahlen,
Am Ende hatten wir dann so ein vier bis fünf Prozent noch Abweichung von der theoretischen Vorhersage. Danach sagt's dann gut genug. Für alle Optiken muss man ja wissen, wie viel Transparenz und.
Also also es geht darum, wie wie viel Photonen kann das kann der Sensor tatsächlich zählen quasi.
Genau. Man muss ja nachher auch die Belichtungszeit einstellen, ähnlich wie beim Fotografieren, dass man nicht überbelichtet und nicht unterbelichtet, muss man ja wissen, wie,
hell ist der Stern dann und es gibt ja verschiedene farbige Sterne, also für verschiedene Spektraltypen wie sensitiv ist unser Teleskop.
Alphazentari ist da ein guter Messpunkt, weil's sehr nah und.
Jetzt als Beispiel gesagt, dass das war nicht den, den wir genommen haben, sorry, aber irgendwelche HD-Nummern genommen, die gerade die richtige Helligkeitsbereich hatten und grad gut sichtbar waren.
Die Standardkerze in dem Moment waren. Mhm. Okay. Das heißt, in dem Moment wusste man wir schauen in die richtige Richtung,
und
Können auch das, was da an Daten kommt, in eine korrekte Wahrnehmung übersetzen. Also wir wir wir wissen, was quasi diese ganzen Messergebnisse der einzelnen Instrumente tatsächlich bedeuten.
Abzüglich einer gewissen Schwankung, die sich dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht weiter ja, die sich einfach nicht rausrechnen lässt, die man dann einfach so hinnehmen muss.
Damit sind wir im Prinzip ja bei dem Instrument von.
Kleiner Satellit und er hat ja eigentlich nur ein einziges Instrument eben diesen Helligkeitssensor, aber da liegt die ganze Konzentration drauf, weil das ist ja die Information, die man haben will. Das heißt, das Ding ist im Wesentlichen einfach ein Auge, was,
sehr genau die Helligkeit eines beliebigen Sterns wahrnehmen kann. Wie setzt man das jetzt,
Also was was unterscheidet dann jetzt auch dieses Teleskop von von anderen Weltraumteleskopen, also ist das dann,
Haben ja auch eine Öffnung und nehmen die anderen nehmen ja auch Licht auf. Sehr viel sensitiver nehme ich an.
Jein, also Sensitivität ist für uns nicht so wichtig. Für uns ist wichtig die Stabilität. Also wir wollten ja diese 20 parts familien messen,
dass er keine absolute Größe, eine relative Größe. Das heißt, was immer wir messen, muss konstant sein auf 20 Millionenstelteile.
Das heißt, der Fokus liegt auf,
alle Größen müssen sehr stabil sein, das heißt die Ausleseelektronik, irgendwann müssen ja die Elec, also die Photonen fallen ja auf die Silizium,
und erzeugen dort Elektronen, werden dort gefangen und irgendwann werden die dann ausgelesen und von einem analog Digitalkonverter in irgendwelche Einheiten umgewandelt.
Und natürlich, wenn ich die Spannung an diesem ADC ändere, ändere ich das Signal. Also die Spannung muss,
Sibias Spannungen, sagt man denen, müssen extremst konstant gehalten werden auf Mikrovolt,
und ebenso müssen sämtliche Temperaturen auch vom Teleskop konstant gehalten werden, damit sich das Telekop nicht verzieht während der Messung,
Auch der Spiegel darf sie nicht ausdehnen und schrumpfen, weil dann wird er die effektive,
Lichtsammelfläche sich ändern. Also hat man dann so ein Zerotourglas, das ist ein Glas, was ich fast nicht ausdehnt bei Temperaturänderung.
Und und zusätzlich wird alles aktiv kontrolliert. Also das Teleskop ist immer auf minus zehn Grad aktiv kontrolliert, stabil und der Detektor, der Chip ist auf minus 45 Grad auf ein Milligrad. Mili Calvin genau.
Für einen Milli Calvin genau.
muss es die Temperatur halten und die Ausleseelektronik ist auch auf einen Militävin stabil.
Wie kann man denn das regeln, wenn das eine passive Kühlung ist? Man hat ja eigentlich gar keinen Einfluss. Sonnenstrahlen kommen an oder kommen nicht an.
Man macht das eben so, dass man erstmals nimmt man guten Orbit, das heißt wir haben wir wir wir das Raumschiff dreht sich immer, es nennt sich Nah-Dialog, das heißt, es schaut immer mit den mit den Metallplatten, die die,
Strahlung abgeben immer von der Erde weg. Also wie man's Weltall also wenn's um die aller drei dreht sich's immer mit, dass immer wegschaut. Außerdem,
Das wollte ich vorher noch sagen zur Standardplattform, also die Standardplattform hat nämlich einige Modifikation. Die eine Modifikation ist eben, dass die Solarzellen so angeordnet sind, dass sie Schatten machen für unsere,
Radiatoren.
Mhm. Ist da nie Sonne drauf fallen kann. Mhm.
Da nie Sonne drauf fallen kann. Gibt's extra so ein Sonnenschild und die ganzen Solarzellen gehen auch immer so halb rundum, dass die Sonne alle Richtungen, in denen wir laut Spezifikationen hinschauen dürfen zu einem gewissen Zeit des Jahres,
scheint die Sonne halt nie dorthin, wo sie nicht hinscheinen soll. Und auch die Erde, die Infrarotstrahlung der warmen Erde kommt so gut wie nicht auf dieser auf diese abstrahlenden Platten.
Schon mal relativ stabil, da waren sie nicht stabil genug. Und was man dann macht, man man kühlt passiv und heizt auf eine gewisse Temperatur. Also sagen wir halt die CCD, wenn wir die nicht heizen würden, würde die ungefähr minus 140 Grad kalt werden.
Heizen sie dann auf - 45 mit einem PRD Controller, also,
klassischer Regelungstechnik, er war an ausschaltet mit Pulsmodulation das Verfahren wie lange die Heizzyklen sind.
Verstehe. Also man hat einfach rein baulich machen wir es erstmal so kalt wie's geht. Damit,
das nicht stören kann und nicht dazwischen kommt und dann hat man wiederum die Möglichkeit von der anderen Seite zu kommen und sagen, jetzt machen wir's fahren wir das Ding einfach genau auf die Temperatur, die wir brauchen.
Pfiffig.
Ja, macht man aber Standardmäßig so. Schwierigkeit bei uns eben ist es ja genau sein muss. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Telekommunikationssatellitenpower mache ich's eigentlich genauso,
Da geht's mehr darum, dass du nicht überhitzt und und dass er innerhalb seinen zehn Grad Arbeitsbereich ist und bei uns ist halt nicht zehn Grad, sondern Mili Kevin. Ist halt ein bisschen schwieriger, aber das Prinzip ist gleich.
So, das heißt,
Das Teleskop in Place schaut an die richtige Stelle, hat die richtige Temperatur. Man weiß, was die ganzen Instrumente, wie man die Daten zu interpretieren hat.
Worauf wird denn jetzt eigentlich geguckt? Wo kommen denn die Objekte jetzt her?
Wir hatten ja vorhin schon gesagt, es geht ja hier nicht dadrum, neue Exo-Planeten zu finden, sondern es geht ja darum, bestehende genauer zu untersuchen. Welche sind das? Wie viele sind das und und und wo kommen die her und warum.
Na gut, als als allererstes haben wir natürlich bekannte Sterne angeschaut, die schon von anderen Teleskopen beobachtet worden sind, einfach mal um zu vergleichen.
Auf die selben Ergebnisse kommt.
Und noch vorher haben wir irgendwelche Standardkerzen angeschaut, die einfach wohl davon ausgehen, dass sie maximal konstant sind, weil Sterne sind ja nicht immer konstant, manche mehr, mal weniger unsere Sonne ist super konstant für einen Stern,
Um einfach mal zu verifizieren noch in im Teil des als Teil der Inbetriebnahme, dass wir unsere zwanzig PPM erreichen.
Nachdem wir das dann geschafft hatten, haben wir dann angefangen im wissenschaftliche Ziele. Das war dann im April es geht schon schon von Weihnachten bis,
am 25. März hatten wir offizielle Commissioning erfolgreich.
Und dann ging's im April los mit den nominalen Wissenschaft. Da gibt's eben ein Science-Team. Also wir haben 80 Prozent der Zeit für die das Konzertum, dass das gebaut hat,
20 Prozent der Zeit ist ESA-Zeit, wo sie Eser auf jährliche,
AO heißt das, announcement of Opportunity. wo man eben Anträge einreichen kann. Dann gibt's einen Komitee, was halt sagt, das ist ein gutes Wissenschaft, kriegst du unsere Stunden Beratungszeit.
Und bei unserem Science-Team,
Die Ziele kommen von unterschiedlichen Quellen. Entweder sind eben mit Tradialgeschwindigkeitsmethode am Boden wirklich Planeten gefunden worden und man,
Vermutet von der Konfiguration her, das sind Transit machen könnte, dann weiß man wann und dann sagt man halt okay in vier Wochen drei Uhr nachmittags ist der Transit. Wenn er denn stattfindet und dann gibt man das ein.
Also Transitz ist, wenn der Exoplanet vor der vor dem Stern vorbei zieht.
Genau, wenn er vor dem Stand vorbei zieht, aber man weiß, weil in diesem Fall genau wann, weil man ja die Geometrie kennt,
Sagt man halt, okay, der Transit dauert zum Beispiel drei Stunden. Wir fangen vielleicht sechs Stunden vorher an und sechs Stunden danach und gibt man eben die zehn5 Stunden als Beobachtungsrequist ins mit dem System programmiert halt, wo man's eingeben kann.
ist das ja periodisch. Sagen wir alle 30 Tage oder was immer die Umlaufzeit um den Stern ist, gibt man halt ein, kannst die in alle 30 Tage beobachten und das unser Planungssystem sucht sich dann halt immer für,
für die nächste Woche waren einmal pro Woche ein Planungszyklus sucht sich sozusagen wieder die nächsten,
Sieben Tage lang die Beobachtungen zusammen möglichst wenig Leerlauf dazwischen zu haben und die möglichst interessanten Objekte nach einem Prioritätenliste eben,
einzuplanen.
Aber wenn wenn jetzt der Satellit selbst einmal um die Erde was haben wir gesagt, anderthalb Stunden braucht, dann kann er ja nicht permanent auf ein ein Objekt schauen.
Doch schon. Also je nachdem woher wo das Objekt ist. Also wir haben eben diesen Orbit-Zoo gewählt. Sonnensynchron,
So vorstellen, wir fliegen über der Tag-Nacht-Grenze, also rechts sagen wir mal, wenn's auf der einen Seite die Sonne die Erde anscheint, auf der anderen Seite ist dunkel fliegen wir im Idealfall genau über diesem.
Graubereich sozusagen, in der Dämmer.
Bereich. Und wir und wir schauen von der Sonne weg. Aber wir können sowieso nicht zur Sonne schauen. Also wir können so so hundertachtzig Grad.
Zur Seite sozusagen.
Von der Sonne weg. Genau man schaut zur Seite und und in diesem Feld diese Konus mit 60 Grad Halbwinkel können wir alles angucken.
Ah ja okay, verstehe.
Dann kommt schon je nachdem also wenn ihr genau von der Sonne wegkommt könnt ihr ununterbrochen beobachten,
mit einer kleinen Problematik kann ich noch kurz drauf eingehen, aber wenn man ein bisschen mehr sagen wir am Rand der Beobachtungszone schaut, dann kommt dann schon die Erde immer wieder,
dazwischen. Dann gibt's halt Unterbrechungen. Also wir haben halt manche Beobachtungen bis zu 50 Prozent unterbrochen, erlauben wir,
aber es gibt auch Beobachtungen wo es quasi keine Unterbrechung gibt. Es gibt nur eine Sache, wo die wir nicht umhin können. Das ist die sogenannte South Atlantic Anomely.
Das heißt, dass wir alle.
Ja immer zwei, drei Umläufe sind ohne, dann kommen wieder zwei, drei Umläufe mit und dann wieder zwei, drei Umläufe ohne, da fliegen wir doch ein Gebiet über dem Südatlantik, deswegen heißt's auch Südatlantik Anomalie.
Van Ellen Strahlungsgürtel so tief runterkommen, dass wir doch in einem Protonen,
Fliegen und dann zieht man einfach nichts mehr offen. das sieht dann aus wie eine Frau wie ein alter Fernseher, der rauscht. Weil wir so viele Teilchen Einschläge aufm Detektor haben.
So Brasilien und eben Südatlantik so diese diese Gegend ist das.
Da kommen einfach diese Besteuerungsgürtel, die normal so auf tausend, tausend1zweihundert Kilometer Höhe sind, kommen die da drunter bis auf 5, 600 Kilometer und da fliegt man halt voll durch.
Da kann man halt nicht die ganze Zeit zuschauen. Okay, aber ansonsten hat man dann doch einen relativ guten Weg. Das heißt, es gibt so high quality Tages, wo man sozusagen die ganze Zeit hinschauen kann und das hängt natürlich dann auch mal von der Jahreszeit ab, weil je nachdem wie weit man denn jetzt sozusagen mit der Erde um diese.
Die Sonne herum ist, hat man einen anderen Blickwinkel und dann sagt man sich.
Extrem gesagt, wenn der Stern hinter der Sonne gerade steht, können wir ihn natürlich nicht beobachten. Mhm. sondern alles, was so dem Drittel des Himmels und wir können typischerweise eine Bergsu drei bis maximal vier Monate lang beobachten.
Genau in die andere Richtung ist, wenn's sozusagen in Richtung also von der Sonne weg ist, dann kann man sozusagen auch nur die Hälfte der Zeit beobachten, weil man ja eigentlich da die ganze Zeit.
Ist ja unser Arbeit ist ja immer so, dass er dass er von der Erde weggeht. Also eigentlich,
können wir in dem Bereich, wo wir beobachten können, es ist so bei der Ecliptik plus - 60 Grad können wir eigentlich dann drei Monate lang beobachten.
Vom Beobachtungsbereich ist desto mehr haben wir diese,
er Unterbrechungen, weil die Erde quasi ins Blickfeld kommt. was wir nicht können, ist die galaktischen Pole. Einfach weil wir nicht senkrecht uns wir können das Raumschiff nicht senkrecht zur Sonne drehen und zu den galaktischen Polen schauen.
Und wie lange dauert das, wenn man jetzt ein neues Ziel in Angriff nimmt? Wie schnell kann man sich da so ausrichten? Ist das mal so eben oder.
Geht schnell. Es dauert so eine Minute zwei dieser Slow sagt man dem, also das ist,
und wir haben glaube ich jetzt meistens so vom Planungssystem so acht Minuten für so einen Wechsel, also wenn man,
Instrumente ist dann aus oder ist es im Stand bye, nimmt dann immer Daten, die sie aber löscht sozusagen mit der Detektor immer die gleiche Temperatur hat und dann fährt das Raumschiff dreht sich mit den Schwungrädern auf die neue Position,
und mit einem.
Zeitlich vorkoordinierten Befehle. Wir haben sagen wir mal TimeTech Commander das Raumschiff hat so eine Mission Timeline heißt die, also eine Zeitlinie, wo alle,
Telekommandos quasi hochgeladen werden mit einer Uhrzeit versehen und immer bei der Uhrzeit wird es ausgelöst und dann wenn halt dann dann wird halt der Kommando ausgelöst,
Instrument beginne die Messung,
fängt das Instrument an zu messen und was wir wir messen nicht nur die Bilder, sondern wir bestimmen auch genau wo der Stern ist,
das Laufen dem Raumschiff, damit's noch Feinjustierung der Position machen kann. Aber das das sind dann schon wissenschaftlich nutzbare Bilder.
Es wird einfach die ganze Zeit nachgetrackt, weil sonst gibt's eben thermoelastische Veränderungen.
Würde der Stern sonst so ein, zwei Pixel sich vielleicht bewegen auf dem Detect und das will man nicht. Deswegen schickt man das immer dem Raumschiff und das Raumschiff berücksichtigt dann das und behält den Stern eigentlich immer am gleichen Pixel.
So und jetzt ist es aber so, dass dass der Blick, den man da ins All wirft, bewusst und scharf ist. Was hat es damit auf sich.
Sind eigentlich zwei Gründe. Der der eine Grund ist ganz banal. Wenn man 30 Zentimeter Teleskop, das ist ja sehr winzig kleines, aber wir wollen eben auch sehr helle Sterne beobachten. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel,
Alpha Zantauri anschauen wollen,
dann können wir dann nur irgendwie sieben Millisekunden oder so belichten bevor bevor der CCD schon satoriert ist,
überbelichtet ist. das ist jetzt ein Extrembeispiel, weil er so helle Sterne gibt's nicht viel und dafür sind wir auch nicht designt worden, aber,
Unsere hellsten Sterne sind sechste Größe und wenn wir das auf einen Punkt fokussieren würden, auf den Detektor könnten wir die nicht beobachten. Allein schon deswegen muss man so viele,
Pixel verteilen, was uns viel zu viel Licht da ist. Wir können nicht so schnell belichten. Also wir haben einen CCD, das einmal auszulesen, dauert eine Sekunde. Selbst wenn wir nur das Fenster auslesen, was uns interessiert,
Also wer die kürzeste Belichtungszeit, die wir machen können, ohne was zu verlieren, wenn wir warten während es ausliest, ist eine Sekunde.
Also verteilt man's in unserem Falle von für 1000 Pixel. Das kann man tausendmal länger belichten, bevor die Überbelichtung.
Pixel hatte in der Sensor.
Hat eine Million Pixels und einen tausendmal tausend. Aber wir verwenden eigentlich nur zweihundert mal zweihundert,
regelmäßig, also die wir runterladen, weil der Stern hat dann Durchmesser von zwanzig Radius oder doch mal zum Beispiel überlegen. Radius, also Durchmesser von vierzig Pixeln ist so ein Block, ein bisschen Dreiecksförmig, passend zu Keops,
nicht wirklich gewollt,
Würde eigentlich ein viel kleinerer Ausschnitt reichen, aber um auch den ganzen Hintergrund bestimmen zu können. Hintergrundniveau der, den man hier abziehen muss. machen wir immer zweihundert mal zweihundert.
Sozusagen als Referenz auch wiederum für den Dunkelstrom.
Nur dunkel Strom, auch Streulicht und andere Sterne, die da im Hintergrund sind.
Mhm. Okay. Das heißt, so muss man sich das vorstellen. Man man visiert im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes jetzt den Stern an, um den es geht,
hat einen riesigen Sensor eigentlich und nutzt davon, na ja so fünf bis zehn Prozent der Fläche ungefähr
Um den eigentlichen Stellen zu machen, schaut aber bewusst unscharf hin, weil es geht ja nicht darum, ein Foto zu machen. Man will ja nur die Helligkeit haben, ne und nutzt damit eben sehr viele mehr Pixel aus und verhindert damit eine Überbelichtung, aber man kriegt ja in der Summe dann eben quasi,
immer noch dieselbe Information und die dann eben auch sehr viel genauer.
Genau. Das war ein Grund jetzt habe gesagt, ich habe zwei Gründe. Der zweite Grund ist, dass ja jedes Pixel hat eine andere Empfindlichkeit,
So typischerweise bei sagt man so drei Prozent von Pixel to Pixel unterscheidet sich und drei Prozent klingt nicht viel aber wenn man auf ein Hundertstelprozent genau oder ein Tausendstel Prozent genau messen möchte, dann ist es natürlich ein Problem. Drei Prozent,
Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt will, das Licht ist immer nur am selben Pixel wär's kein Problem, aber weil das Raumschiff halt immer ein bisschen rum eiert ähm,
wird immer sich's auf mehrere Pixeln und dann ist wär's eine Katastrophe. Man kann das jetzt kalibrieren. Also wir haben das auf ein Zehntelprozent kalibriert im Labor dieses sogenannte Flatfield,
Also quasi die die Empfindlichkeitslandkarte des Chips.
Die eine statische Größe ist, also man weiß oder ändert die Pixel dann auch noch.
Gehen jetzt davon aus, dass sie sich nicht ändern, aber das weiß keiner genau auf dem Level von zwanzig PPM. Aber es scheint schon wahrscheinlich so zu sein, dass es sich nicht ändern. Alles was im Labor, weil oben können wir's nicht mehr so genau messen,
und im Labor haben wir es eben auf dem Zehntel Prozent genau gemessen und das benutzen wir jetzt als Kalibrationsgröße. Aber wir sind Gott sei Dank nicht so stark davon abhängig, weil dadurch, dass wir das eben nicht, dass wir nicht nur einen Pixel messen, sondern eben tausend.
Mittelt sich das ja statistisch ein bisschen raus und man kann eben dann rein mathematisch oder reicht es selbst das Zehntelprozent nicht, aber wenn wir eben tausendmal ein Zehntel-Prozent haben, dann sind wir schon mal,
irgendwie Faktor dreißig, vierzig besser, doch Wurzel aus der Anzahl der Punkte. und so schafft man eben diese zwanzig BPM.
Sagen wir so, ist eine Möglichkeit, dass es zu schaffen gibt, viele Möglichkeiten.
Aber andere machen einfach eine wahnsinnig gute Lagerregelung. Kepler zum Beispiel, dass Millionen Sterne angeschaut hat, wo jeder Stern wirklich nur auf einem Pixel ist muss dann die Lageregelung halt so gut sein, dass das auch wirklich auf diesem einen Pixel bleibt,
dann sogar im Pixel gibt's unterschiedlich, wie man sagt, auch Intrapixler sind die Sensitivitäten unterschiedlich.
Echt? Mhm.
Muss man dann auch charakterisieren.
Krass.
Okay, jetzt ist die Mission ja schon eine Weile unterwegs und die Kalibrationsphasen sind ging schon lange zurück. Das Ding ist in Betrieb und wird benutzt und von allen möglichen Wissenschaftlern sind dann quasi,
Ziele eingereicht worden. So hier das wollen wir uns gerne mal anschauen. Was,
Hat denn die Mission da jetzt bisher geleistet? Also wie viele Sterne sind da schon untersucht worden und was,
Was genau kann man damit jetzt eigentlich herausfinden und was ist bisher vielleicht an interessanten Entdeckungen auch schon gemacht worden?
Mhm. Also wir haben wir hatten schon im Frühjahr hatten wir unseren 1tausendste Beobachtung,
Also das kann man sich ungefähr Beobachtungen dauern eben immer zwischen paar Stunden. Kürzeste Beobachtung, wie wir machen können, ist ein Orbit, also,
anderthalb Stunden,
Es gibt auch mal Beobachtungen, die ja 48 oder 72 Stunden lang sind oder wir haben auch einmal eine Woche und noch mal drei Tage beobachtet. Wir können nicht länger als eine Woche am Stück beobachten.
Aber in diesem in dieser Bandbreite bewegt sich das und wir haben so ungefähr 300 Ziele angeschaut,
Manche davon sehr häufig, manche nur einmal, also es ist ganz unterschiedlich hier nach wenn man jetzt nur was bestätigen möchte, nur eine Transitmessung kann sein, dass eine einzige Messung reicht,
Wir sind typischerweise mit einer einzigen Messung so ungefähr dreimal genauer als Test. Also diese amerikanische Satellit,
der für uns eigentlich ein großer Gewinn ist, weil er was ähnliches und doch was ganz was anderes macht als wir. Also der schaut auch helle Sterne an,
versucht den ganzen Himmel abzugrasen, hat aber immer nur 27 Tage pro Stern und dann ist er wieder weiter beim nächsten,
Können halt immer noch mal genauer hinschauen. Jederzeit wann wir Lust haben und mehrere Messungen machen und das sehr eine sehr gute ergänzt sich sehr gut.
Ja, zu den konkreten Ergebnissen, also ist natürlich jetzt der persönliche,
Geschmackssache. Also ich fand's sehr spannend. Also ganz am Anfang war einfach mal spannend, da hatten wir den,
198 der ein sehr heißer hot Chupetor ist, das heißt quasi ein großer Gasplanet,
wo man eben nicht nur den Transit messen kann, sondern auch den Eclipse. Also es muss sich das so vorstellen. Franzi deckt der Planet den Stern ab. Und bei der Clips deckt der Stern den Planet ab.
Weil der Planet ja Licht zum einen reflektiert und zum anderen auch thermisch ein bisschen aussendet,
sieht man das, wenn man sehr genau hinschaut, denn in diesem Fall sind das 84 PPM ein sehr großer Planet,
und man kann dann eben daraus schließen, dass er wie die Atmosphäre aussieht, das ist hauptsächlich reflektiert das Licht,
Für uns aber auch das Schöne, dass wir das auf vier PPM genau messen konnten, diesen Dip. Also das war einfach mal eine Leistungsbeweis von.
Man so genau hinschauen kann und die Atmosphären Leute, die können dann halt dort Albedo Rückschlüsse ziehen, welche bestimmte Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre ausschließen und so weiter.
Mhm. Weil man einfach weiß, okay so und so viel Reflexionspotenzial hat diese Atmosphäre und das gibt Rückschlüsse auf entweder die Beschaffenheit oder man kann's besser.
Gibt's Wolken, gibt's keine Wolken, zum Beispiel gibt's Stau und Atmosphäre und so. Und dann das etwas Neuer war, es ähm,
I eins sieben acht das ist einfach so eine Nummer wie bei all diesen Sachen und da haben wir eben.
Zuerst war die Idee, es gibt einen Co-Orbitle-Planeten, also das heißt sind ja alle Planeten, die Erde ist auf ihrer Umlaufbahn allein,
nicht noch eine Erde mit einem Jahr Umlaufzeit, die auf der anderen Seite der Sonne um die Sonne kreist. Und es gab in in den Daten, ich glaube in Keplerdaten vor allem, gab's eben ein Signal, aber,
dass dort vielleicht ein so ein ist, also ein das wäre der erste und hat ihm eine Gruppe von unseren Wissenschaftlern halt da genauer hingeschaut,
Genauer gemessen und am Ende kam heraus, ist kein weil es wäre natürlich höchst spannend. Kann sowas überhaupt entstehen? Zwei Planeten, die sich die eine Umlaufbahn teilen.
Aber es sind Resonanzen, das heißt wir haben dann dort sechs Planeten total gefunden,
also mindestens zwei waren davon glaube ich vorher nicht bekannt und die sind alle in Resonanz, das heißt wenn der eine Planet zum Beispiel vier Umläufe macht, macht der andere drei Umläufe und eine 16 Umläufe macht, macht der andere fünf, so dass dann immer zum gleichen Zeitpunkt zwei Planeten,
oder auch in der in der Hälfte der Zeit, deswegen sah es so aus, als wäre man in der Hälfte der Zeit da noch ein Planet ist.
Da hat man dann eben ein ein Planetensystem gefunden von sechs Planeten, die zwar alle sehr nah am Stern sind, also ich glaube so Ängste hat ein paar Tage Umlaufzeit und der weiteste,
paar zehn Tage, also viel alles viel geschrumpfter als unser Sonnensystem. Aber fünf von diesen sechs Planeten nenne ich mich recht erinnere, sind alle in Resonanz.
Und das hat extreme,
Einschränkungen auf wie die entstanden sein können, weil die kleinste Störung würde diese Resonanz zerstören. Das heißt ist für die von einem Planeten Entstehungsperspektive extrem interessant.
Hinzu kommt noch, dass es recht helles System ist, was er so gut untersuchen kann.
Ja und dann gab's noch also das Griechisch zwei Lupi im Lupus-Sternbild. Das ein Sternekammer quasi mit einem bloßen Auge sehen, weil er so fünfte größer hell ist fünf Komma irgendwas.
Also von der Erde aus, wenn man nach oben schaut. Ja. Mhm.
Ich das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr kann, aber ich sage jetzt mal ein 15-jähriger mit guten Augen, in einer klaren Nacht kann das sehen, den Stern.
Mhm. Und dann von meinem guten Teleskop sowieso.
Sowieso auch mit jedem billigsten Teleskop, kann man das sehen? Und dort kann man sehen, einen 100 Tage Umlaufzeitplaneten entdeckt.
Und das ist eben schwierig, also,
Erde hat ein Jahr, also 365 Tage, aber da macht natürlich dann auch, wenn wir jetzt Außerirdische wären und uns selbst beobachten würden, hat man jedes Jahr eine Chancen-Transe zu sehen.
Und das berücksichtigt noch nicht, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Geometrie richtig ist, auch immer abnimmt, je weiter man weg ist,
wahnsinnig schwer zu finden, aber eigentlich sind das die interessantesten, weil wenn wir von einem erdännlichen Planeten sprechen, denkt man ja so, ein Jahr geht ein Jahr und ein Jahr geht nicht 20 Tage,
ist dann auch viel zu heiß, wenn's ein Jahr zwanzig Tage geht, wenn's ein sonnenähnlicher Stern ist und das ist eben einer, der der 100 Tage Umlaufzeit hat und der wurde da.
Entdeckt einfach auf, ob's flexibel ist und dann war zufällig in einem Window waren nicht erwartet da Transit und dann kann man halt sich überlegen, wann könnte der wieder vor auftreten?
Haben sie neben gefunden. Aber beim TIO 1sieben acht war's auch so, dass man zuerst fünf Planeten hatte und dann hat man gesagt, jetzt machen die so eine schöne Resonanzkette.
Da fehlt noch einer. Genau hier in der Mitte. Lass uns doch mal gucken. Genau an dem Tag, wann der und dann war da einer.
Das ist halt das Schöne bei einfach eingeben kann. Ich möchte an dem Tag beobachten um die Uhrzeit und es wäre so eine schöne Resonanz. Fehlt nur noch ein Planet.
Wäre doch schön, wenn er eine ist und dann haben sie hingeschaut und hat geklappt. Also.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, die Nachfrage nach Beobachtungszeit ist nachgefragt.
Ja also im im Science Team, wo die eben elf Länder drin sind und da gibt's natürlich ständig, möchte nicht sagen Kämpfe, aber,
Also der Science Team Chair, die Diekelot muss immer wieder sagen, beschränkt euch aufs Wesentliche, also es nützt nichts zwölf Projekte anzufangen und keins fertig zu machen, sondern machen schön der Reihe nach, dass man auch genügend Beobachtungen kriegt.,
Aber lustigerweise auf Eser Seite mit den 20 Prozent ist eher wenig Interesse. Also man würde ja erwarten, dass es völlig over subscribed ist.
Ja, würde ich erwarten.
Das ist es nicht,
wir wissen nicht genau warum. Ein Grund ist sicher, dass zeitgleich die Testmission gestartet ist und die Testdaten werden alle nach sechs Monaten öffentlich verfügbar.
Und man kann dann gibt dann hunderttausende von Lichtkurven die man angucken kann quasi gratis ohne einen Antrag zu schreiben,
und bei ist es die Schwelle halt ein bisschen höher, muss ein wissenschaftliche Begründung, Antrag schreiben,
und so weiter. Das ist sicher ein Grund weiter Grund könnte sein, das wollen wir jetzt für die Missionserweiterung verbessern,
wir natürlich als Konsortium mit unseren 80% Beobachtungszeit,
momentan so geregelt, dass man wenn wir was beobachten, es ist blockiert. Also dann kann man nicht weiter kein Antrag auf den selben Stern, weil es macht irgendwie keinen Sinn. Wenn zwei Leute das Gleiche anschauen und es quasi vergeudete Beobachtungszeit,
aber es kann sein, dass dadurch, dass wir natürlich die interessantesten Objekte anschauen,
dass dann zu viele versuchen zu schauen, ist dann schon blockiert. Deswegen wollen wir jetzt im für die Erweiterung haben wir gesagt, wir reduzieren dramatisch unsere reservierte Zielliste.
Um mehr Möglichkeiten zu geben, Leuten das zu beobachten, was sie beobachten wollen. Also wir wissen nicht, ob das ein Grund ist, aber es könnte ein Grund sein, dass vielleicht zu viel blockiert ist.
Interessant. Obwohl ja, ich meine, gut Tes Test veröffentlicht alle Daten nach sechs Monaten, das ist dann hier nicht der Fall.
Veröffentlichen alle Daten nach einem Jahr nach der letzten Beobachtung oder anderthalb Jahre nach der ersten Beobachtung.
Und das macht man deshalb nur so spät, weil.
Ja, weil die Leute, die sich die ganze Mühe gemacht haben, mit muss ja teilweise auch noch Bodennachver Verfolgung initiieren, damit man auch eine Chance hat, dann das zu veröffentlichen, bevor es jemand anders veröffentlicht. Das ist schon relativ viel Aufwand und man muss sich vorstellen,
Man muss ja genau wissen, wann man hinguckt und das manchmal nicht so leicht, weil diese Fermeriden, sagen wir dem Fermariots,
Wann genau der Planet in Transit macht, weiß man vielleicht irgendwann mal, aber über die Monate und Jahre wird's immer ungenauer und man muss dann irgendwie versuchen zu erraten oder zu berechnen oder nochmal einen Boden gestützte Radialgeschwindigkeitsmessung zu machen, um noch mal,
nicht mit Keyboards auf jeden sterben. Drei Wochen schauen, um einen Transit zu finden und ist mit relativ viel Aufwand verbunden.
Das dann auch ordentlich zu machen und nicht vorbeizuwerfen. Ich kann mich jetzt eigentlich nur ein oder zwei Mal erinnern, wo sie wirklich dann falsch waren und wir haben verpasst haben den Transit.
Und einfach um die Leute, die die Arbeit auch auch zu zu.
Honorieren, dass man da sozusagen auch die Möglichkeit hat, was Wissenschaftliches zu publizieren, weil das.
Viele Doktoranden, die das machen.
Das ist ja ein bisschen auch der Lohn der Arbeit in der in der Wissenschaft. Aber am Ende landen die Daten alle öffentlich.
Am Ende landen die alle öffentlich, ja.
Mhm. So,
Dezember neunzehn, jetzt haben wir Ende einundzwanzig, zwei Jahre sind rum und ich glaube, die Regelzeit der Mission liegt bei dreieinhalb Jahren. ist dann schon alles alle.
Treibstoff oder lässt sich noch was erweitern.
Also technisch gesehen können wir sehr lange beobachten. Also wir haben wir brauchen keinen Treibstoff. Also wir brauchen Treibstoff nur für Kollisionsvermeidung.
Um am Ende sauber sozusagen den Orbit zu verlassen und nicht selbst als Weltraumschrott zu enden. ansonsten brauchen wir überhaupt gar kein Consumerbus, wie sagt man denn, auf auf Deutsch.
Verbrauchsmaterialien. Mhm.
weil wir nur Strom brauchen und.
Solange die Technik funktioniert, funktioniert.
Dann ist die Frage, funktioniert sie noch oder nicht? Das es kann ja immer mal sein, dass ein Schwungrad ausfällt. Wenn dann das Zweite ausfällt, dann sind wir nicht mehr fähig. Wahrscheinlich gute Ausrichtung zu machen.
Aber noch gehen alle.
Noch geht alles. und was unsere Hauptlimitierende Faktor sein wird. Also wenn nicht irgendein Elektronikbauteil auch hochenergetisch Teilchen getrocknet einfach kaputt ist,
ist der Detektor. Der Tektor,
ist ein normaler CCD-Detektor und der hat einen optimiert auf sehr sehr geringen Dunkelstrom und sehr hohe konstant von der von von der Sensitivität her,
aber er wird ständig von Teilchen bombardiert, insbesondere wenn wir dieses Haushalt lebendiger Nomely durchqueren und wir haben ungefähr einhundert,
neue, sogenannte heiße Pixel, Hotpixel pro Tag. Ein ein heißes Pixel heißt einfach, dass es,
nicht quasi keinen Dunkelstrom produziert, sondern ein normales Pixel produziert,
In einer Minute vielleicht ein Countdown Dunkelstrom und man kann 65.000 Counts Licht sammeln pro Pixel, sondern die produzieren dann halt plötzlich,
nicht unterschiedlich von von eins bis zehntausend pro Sekunde oder so. Das sind einfach dann heiß. Wir sagen den Hot Pixels.
Ja, warum weiß man nicht so ganz genau, man muss sich so vorstellen, das ist ja ein ist ein wird das beschädigt. Das ist quasi ein monochristalines Silizium.
Die Teilchen, die Protonen zum Beispiel zerstören das Kristallgitter. Und machen dort Fehlerfehlstellen,
im im Kristall und dann ist der Abstand zum Leitungsband, der wo diesen Dunkelströmerzeug plötzlich viel kleiner und dann gibt's viel mehr Dunkelstrom. Aber es gibt verschiedene Mechanismen. Im Wesentlichen muss ich vorstellen, sind Beschädigungen der Kristallstruktur.
Bombardierung mit geladenen Teichen.
Diesen kurzfristigen Blitz erzeugen und langfristig unter Umständen die Qualität des CCD mindern. Genau.
Es gibt auch diese kurzfristigen Blitze, die sehen wir auch immer. Das immer wieder mal so ein kosmisches Ding ist. Aber meistens ist danach alles wieder gut. Manchmal sind danach nicht alles gut, sondern das Pixel ist dann plötzlich hot geworden und hat plötzlich eben viel höhere Dunkelstrom.
Dauerhaft. Manche verschwinden auch wieder. Also es ist wir haben zum Beispiel pro Tag werden 200 neue erzeugt und hundert verschwinden. Aber im Schnitt sind dann 100 neue da, die bleiben.
Das heißt, da ist dann der Dunkelstrom anders. Man muss das quasi anders kalibrieren. Genau. Anders.
Genau. Also wir machen deswegen jede Woche eine Messung, die nur dazu da ist, den Dunkelstrom zu messen und die neuen heißen Pixel zu charakterisieren.
Noch muss man die nicht korrigieren, aber wir arbeiten jetzt dran, dass man die dann immer abzieht aber man muss eben aufpassen und man durchs Abziehen nicht mehr,
Rauschen hineinbringt als durchs Nicht-Abziehen, weil wenn man einfach nur zählt und wenn das heiße Pixel immer perfekt konstant ist, dann stört's eigentlich nicht,
Aber wenn's am Rand ist, wir zählen normalerweise einen gewissen Kreis, alles Licht zum Stern, wenn das Pixel immer rein- und raushüpft zum Beispiel. Ist natürlich schlecht,
limitierende Faktor. Also wir erwarten, dass wir dass wir jetzt haben wir sechs Prozent heiße Pixel. Am Anfang der Mission hatten wir null,
und wir erwarten, dass wir 2028 haben wir jetzt gerechnet ungefähr 30, 40 Prozent heiße Pixel haben.
Die sind dann nicht automatisch unbenutzbar. Man muss nur anders mit ihnen umgehen.
Nein nein also wir haben auch Simulationen gemacht weil wir jetzt eben überlegen wollen wir die Mission verlängern. Die macht ein ein Review aller Mission immer im Drei-Jahrest-Turnus für Verlängerung mögliche Verlängerungen. Da sind wir jetzt auch das erste Mal dabei,
Würden wir dann von Ende September um zwei weitere Jahre verlängern, so weil der Turnus so fällt,
Gerade berechnet, dass wir erwarten in den nächsten drei oder auch sechs Jahren, auch schon für übernächste Verlängerung,
Ja, eigentlich nur zehn Prozent Performance-Einbußen bei den dunkleren Sternen, bei den ganz hellen Sternen ist sowieso kein Problem. Also die ganz hellen Sterne,
Die sind so hell, da machen so ein paar dunkle Strom, Pixeln, nichts aus. Man merkt, sieht man gar nicht.
Also wir hoffen, dass wir weitermachen können, aber es ist natürlich nicht nur eine technische Frage, auch eine finanzielle Frage. Muss ja die das die Bodenstation weiter betreiben, die ganze wissenschaftliche Planung weiter betreiben.
Ich meine, das ist ja dann immer so eine Rechnung, man hat ja sehr viel für den Bau, für die Planung, die ganze Vorarbeit aufgewendet. Das ist ja das bei einer Verlängerung der Mission fällt das ja dann alles nicht mehr ins Gewicht. So, sondern man kriegt ja quasi einfach mehr sozusagen. Klar, man hat dann halt eben regelmäßige Kosten.
Machen denn so die regelmäßigen Dauerbetriebskosten aus im Verhältnis zum Gesamtvolumen. Grob geschätzt.
Ich würde sagen so sind wir schwer zu setzen, weil die Gesamtkosten waren schätzen wir es auf 100 Millionen Euro,
Aber man weiß, bei den Partnerländern nicht genau, wie viel die ausgegeben haben. Es war es dann immer so, Deutschland hat zum Beispiel versprochen, das Kernstück zu liefern, diese super stabile Kamera,
für die Finanzierung zuständig also und haben dann auch geliefert wie er wie gewünscht und funktioniert super. Den kann man nicht genau sagen wie viel Geld zur Ausgabe ungefähr 100 Millionen und wir schätzen ungefähr 1 Prozent der Kosten braucht man so pro Jahr als laufende Kosten.
Okay, also eine Million ist ja eigentlich auch ist ja noch, geht ja noch.
Geht ja noch, aber muss.
Muss auch muss auch erstmal von jemanden bezahlt werden, klar.
Dann aber ich meine von Eser Seite ist es deutlich günstiger. Also die Million war jetzt auf Schweizer und Hauptmissionszeiten wir die gesamte Mission leiten,
Das ist ja auch das Besondere an Keops, dass wir seitdem wir das Commissioning abgeschlossen haben. Wie hat Esa uns die Verantwortung quasi komplett übergeben und wir leiten die Mission komplett allein,
Es ist immer noch beratend und unterstützend dabei. Isa ist auch der launching State. Das heißt, sie sind verantwortlich, wenn das wenn jetzt Keops auf irgendjemanden abstürzen würde.
Wäre schuld. Also haben sie natürlich ein Wörtchen mitzureden, wenn wir dann zum Beispiel die Commissioning machen, dass wir,
alles sauber machen und wir haben auch die volle Unterstützung der Experten, aber wir sind eigentlich verantwortlich das Ding zu leiten und zu managen.
Auch wenn jetzt so Kollisionen drohen, was hier glaube ich auch einmal passiert ist, ne?
Kollision das dann eben so, dass wir einen Service gebucht haben von der von der Space Day Office heißt's so schön. Also Weltraumstrottabteilung,
uns hilft, die Unmengen an Daten, die man von Chasebock, also von Johnson Space-Centern, USA, die diese ganzen Rudertracking machen,
und und eine Datenbank haben, äh.
Weiterzuleiten und zu warnen.
Dann die bekommen dann ganz viele Daten, die für unseren Orbit ungefähr,
relevant sein könnten, aber da muss man auch genauer rechnen, sonst würde man ständig Warnungen bekommen jeden Tag.
Und das machen die für uns und sagen dann, Moment mal, hier ist eine Kollision, dass ich in drei Tagen die hat eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von größer als zehn noch minus vier. wir müssen reden.
Und dann überlegt man gibt's Ausweichmanöver, die man fliegen kann, soll muss, dann wartet dann meistens, wenn die Daten dann immer genauer,
kommt einfach immer näher zum Zeitpunkt und dann wird natürlich der Fehler der Abschätzung des Ortes immer geringer und dann in der Regel kann man dann sagen, okay, wir fliegen einfach weiter,
Und einmal mussten wir ihm ausweichen, aber es macht eben die ESA für uns halt als Service.
Awareness von der Isa. Habe ich auch eine Sendung zu gemacht, kann ich mal drauf verweisen. Raumzeit vierunddreißig, da war das alles
auch am Anfang mit Detlef Koschny
und mit Holger Krag vom habe ich mich auch schon zweimal unterhalten über die Problematik des Weltraum Schrotts und wie gut's da auch beziehungsweise auch wie Schlechtes da voranläuft in dem ganzen Bereich. Da ist ja noch eine ganze Menge zu holen.
Einmal musste Keops ausweichen bisher, ne? Dann hoffen wir mal, dass das nicht so oft passiert. Aber es ist mittlerweile schon ganz schön was los im Orbit.
Trotzdem so ein ein Tipp, also es könnte schon auf eine Erweiterung der Mission zumindest eine hinauslaufen. Ist nicht ganz unwahrschein.
Ich hoffe sehr, ja. Also wir wollen, also von Schweizer Seite, von spanischen Seite gibt's ja positives Signale,
Denke auch von Esa-Seite. Ist so eine kleine Mission aus Eser Sicht. Das ist ja die erste und einzige S-Klass-Mission.
Nicht viel sparen können, indem sie ihre ihre Esarsch-Keops-Beteiligung jetzt zusammenstreichen. Also eine Emission kann man damit nicht ein Jahr lang verlängern,
Also hoffen wir, dass dass es dann am Ende positiv ausgeht. Also wir haben jetzt dieses Review, wo wir jetzt technisch im November diesen Jahres zeigen müssen, dass es eben,
uns nicht der Treibstoff ausgeht, dass wir dann am Ende immer noch sicher die arbeiten können, dass die Wissenschaft immer noch gute Qualität liefern wird,
Das wird dann begutachtet und dann als Grundlage genommen dann für die Abstimmung für die finanzielle Abstimmung. Aber erstmal müssen wir zeigen, dass wir technisch,
gute Wissenschaft liefern können und ich denke, ich kann jetzt sagen,
mit allen Analysen, die wir in den letzten drei Monaten gemacht haben, nur zu diesem Thema, dass das noch gute Wissenschaft bis 2028 sicher möglich sein wird.
Super.
Dann wünsche ich auf jeden Fall viel Erfolg für den Rest der Mission und dass der Rest der Mission noch möglichst lange anhält. ich denke ist auf jeden Fall gerade haben wir ja eingangs auch besprochen. Exoplaneten sind einfach grade,
tolles Thema und da passiert einfach eine Menge der Informationsgewinn ist extrem groß und ja da kann ein Jahr jede Mission, die an der Stelle weiterhilft interessante Beobachtungen zu machen, eigentlich nur hilfreich sein.
Vielen Dank fürs Gespräch. Christopher Brück.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Das war's. die neunundneunzigste Ausgabe. Lasst euch überraschen, was bei der 100 auf euch zukommt. Bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis.